ross gets his 13th start of the season
his fourth year in salem field
he also gets another shot at the tampa
bay rays if you remember he unveiled his
new delivery on may the 24th that was
against the tampa bay rays and he was
sensational seven innings in that ball
game since then he has gone four in one
great era he has dropped his era in six
of his last seven starts his dow now
down to 4
27 for stripling he has been a
magnificent starter for the blue jays
since he made that change
first pitch is a strike and brandon law
puts it in play
crowds out to the second baseman one up
there's a slider hit on the line right
to you bisho who is playing in the shift
two up two down quickly here for
stripping two balls two strikes two outs
from the top of the first
big curve ball hit in the air not deep
george springer the center fielder
waiting on it and that's a quick inning
for ross stripling just 12 pitches he
retires a side in order
shane mcclanahan the race looking for
him to be the stopper we talked already
dwayne they have not won since he last
started that was a week ago
and there you go
simeon out on strikes this stuff is just
too electric and mcclanahan goes with
the slider keeps it in the zone forces a
quick decision by simeon and it's the
wrong decision two up two down vlad
guerrero jr
on the ground
wendell at third the throw to first in
time so a strikeout a couple of round
outs three up three down g-man choi with
the lead at first nobody out we're in
the second
there's a slider slow roller toward
third espana throws in time a rosa reina
can run
well the rays are going to have a look
at the replay it looked like a
rosarian's foot was still in the air
when vladi had that ball touch his glove
ray's lose their challenge challenge
goes away in the second inning springer
has an all-star ahead of him it all-star
behind him
there's a fastball swinging drive get up
get out of here
george springer for a second straight
game hits the first pitch he sees out of
the ballpark
you gotta be ready to hit the number one
and springer did that in last night's
game in his first death bat sending one
out of here on a fastball and he does it
this afternoon
be ready to hit that 100 mile an hour
fastball get that swing started early
catch it out front
and he took a
that pitch way out of here one nothing
jay's
hard hit ball to the third baseman
wendell the second nice play by lau and
then he throws it away
joey wendell's throw from third was not
a good throw low did a heck of a job of
catching the throw in the dirt and then
that threw him off balance and he throws
wide at first
we were talking about defense
overall this season they've been a good
defensive team but lately they haven't
that's a double play ball
now you put yourself in a position where
basic could score two
a little tap right side
and the toss to first dug out by diaz
and across the body throw that bounced
in
the rays get out of that
top of the order simeon goes after the
first pitch
high
short right and there is
margot with the sliding catch boy it
appeared he was having a little
difficulty with that one but managed to
get there go home for one against
stripling today
and he gets into this one gives it a
ride back to the left gurion jr to the
wall
and that ball is out of here
home run for margot
durielle challenged it all the way ran
out of territory that's home run number
nine
four more ago and the rays are on the
board tying this game at one guriel jr
had a shot at it that timing got a
little bit off on the leap
and it just able to clear the glove the
wall
and tie this game up hernandez leading
off the bottom of the fourth
and that's a nice pitch there
down and then disappeared on hernandez
who was out on strikes
and strike three he gets the strikeout
up in the zone that time and ariel
turned around are you kidding me
and one more go who tied the game with
the homer swings the first pitch here
grounds it to short simeon has it and
throws to first
one pitch one out in the six i'm going
to put a star next to that one because
that was such a tricky hop and he made
it look so easy
the changer popped in the air
espionage into foul territory will make
the catch and two quick outs here in the
six for ron stripling
and you get there standing up another
double for guerrero his 16th of the
season that is a laser to left field
most people that's a single because the
outfielder would have been able to get
over there and cut it off
but with his elite bat speed
and exit velocity that thing goes all
the way to the wall
there it is guriel
jr with the bases loaded and one out now
chance for the blue jays to do some
damage
pulled on the ground that's a fair ball
they're going to come home enzamino
can't make the play carrera was safe
zanino looked like he was thinking about
a double play and in his haste to catch
the ball and get a throw off the first
he dropped the baseball 2-1 blue jays
bases remain loaded still one out but
he'd love an extra base hit
there's a fly ball to lafayette this
ball is down for a base hit one run is
in here comes the second round and kevin
bizio drops one inside of the line for a
two run single yeah it's not an extra
base hit but it's the next best thing
santiago espanol still looking for more
runs
swinging and drive get up
here
santiago espina
with his first big league home run
a two-run shot
and the blue jays have busted it wide
open here in the six a deep drive to
left field go up there and look for that
breaking ball he does and knocks it out
of the ballpark
and to give you an idea what his
teammates think of him look at the
celebration in the dugout all the
veterans acknowledging his first big
league home run
two outs here in the ninth
and the ground ball up the middle takes
a big hop and into center field
the rose arena crosses the plate
diaz follows him and the raids make it a
6-3 ball game
there's a fly ball into center and this
will do it jonathan davis is there
that's the ball game
so the rays lose two in a row that's ten
straight road losses for tampa bay